[Música]
muy buenas tardes interrumpimos la
programación habitual de france 24 en
español para llevarles a ustedes los
detalles de lo que sucede en la ciudad
de washington en donde ha comenzado ya
la votación final en donde será definido
el juicio político contra el ex
presidente de donald trump vamos a
conectarnos en minutos con lo que está
sucediendo allí una larga jornada al día
de hoy a lo largo de la mañana les
estuvimos reportando de las diferencias
que hubo en el procedimiento primero
hubo pues confrontación de los
argumentos por parte de los demócratas
luego la defensa también dio su punto de
vista y en un movimiento inesperado la
bancada demócrata pidió llamar algunos
testigos posteriormente ambas bancadas
acordaron que esto retrasaría mucho la
decisión final y decidieron cancelar
después de haber votado y haber aprobado
llevar a algunos testigos y continuaron
simplemente con el proceso de debate de
los argumentos esto lo que sucede en
washington avanza la votación escuchemos
señor karting
culpable ser culpable
señor caising
culpable
si era collins
culpable ser con él
no culpable
el recorte es más culpable
geimer
no culpable o no culpable o no culpable
james no culpable
culpable
ernst no culpable señor
culpable sin gracia en este momento
están votando los senadores los
representantes en la cámara alta del
congreso de eeuu están dando su votación
final con esto quedaría ya definido este
juicio político contra el expresidente
donald trump quien es acusado por haber
apoyado la insurrección del pasado 6 de
ha sido una semana en la que ambas
bancadas tanto los demócratas que son
los que han impulsado este juicio
político han mostrado todos sus
argumentos ante el pleno del senado
vimos a lo largo de la semana la
presentación de vídeos conversaciones
mensajes a través de las redes sociales
en las que la bancada demócrata
argumentó la necesidad de impedir que el
ex presidente de donald trump pueda
ejercer nuevamente un cargo público y
así aspirar a un posible nuevo mandato
presidencial en la siguiente legislatura
luego un día después la defensa de
donald trump intervino y presentó todos
sus argumentos ante el pleno del senado
como corresponde en este tipo de
procesos de juicio político recordemos
que este es el segundo juicio político
al que se somete donald trump el primero
fue en la mitad de su mandato
presidencial
a esa trama y esa relación que podría
haber tenido el presidente al pedir que
fuera investigado el hijo del actual
presidente joe biden y la posible
relación que tenía con algún
empresariado en ucrania finalmente el
senado absolvió al presidente y por eso
continuó con su con su mandato hasta
finalizar y esta iniciativa demócrata
intentó llegar antes de que el
presidente en ese momento donald trump a
terminara su mandato pero las
dificultades para que la cámara alta
comenzará a legislar debido al cambio de
gobierno por retraso el inicio del
juicio del inicio de estas escuchas y
escuchemos precisamente entonces como
avanzada esta votación ya en unos
minutos finalizará y podemos dar una
votación final escuchar
no culpable
culpable
señor martín culpable
señor no señor
no culpable señor merentes culpable
culpable
[Música]
no culpable
cinemark austin
culpable
señor padilla culpable o no culpable
señor pearce
culpable sr
no culpable señorita culpable señor gris
esta sería entonces la votación final de
este juicio político el segundo juicio
político al que se sometió de donald
trump como les estaba contando un juicio
que avanzó a pesar de que donald trump
ya había finalizado su mandato y ya joe
biden del partido demócrata había
asumido la presidencia ambos partidos
acordaron que desarrollarían este juicio
político de la forma más rápida posible
debido a esa agenda que tiene el
gobierno nuevo de eeuu ha encabezado por
joe biden y kamala harris
quiere aprobar diferentes proyectos en
torno a los planes de vacunación a la
inmunización contra el jove 19 el tema
migratorio y unos temas de estímulo
económico para reactivar la economía
después de lo que ha dejado la pandemia
en este país a lo largo del 2020 es por
este motivo que hoy no progresó
inicialmente fue aprobado haber llevado
algunos testigos para dar algunas
versiones sobre los hechos del 6 de
enero pero finalmente las dos bancadas
vieron que estoy va a dilatar muchísimo
el proceso y ante esta agenda que tiene
el gobierno pues será necesario dar una
respuesta a este juicio político el día
de hoy vamos a conectarnos entonces con
cristóbal vázquez nuestro corresponsal
en la ciudad de washington quien a lo
largo del día a lo largo de la semana
nos ha estado reportando y contando todo
lo que sucede el minuto a minuto de lo
que ha pasado allí en el senado en eeuu
cristóbal y hace un rato conversábamos
precisamente sobre las cargas que tiene
este senado en particular son
prácticamente 50/50 las dos bancadas
pero para aprobar la constitucionalidad
de este proceso en el legislativo vimos
que algunos republicanos pues aprobaron
esta constitucionalidad dándole digamos
de ese punto a favor a los demócratas
como estarán entonces las cargas para
esta votación que terminará en unos
minutos
exactamente en contados minutos ya
sabremos si don otro es absuelto o es
hallado culpable de este crimen que se
le acusa de insurrección por haber
incitado a la violencia el 6 de enero
las cargas están pues muy iguales 50
votos republicanos 50 votos demócratas
son las cargas iniciales pero como lo
habíamos visto en los días anteriores
hay aproximadamente 56 senadores
republicanos que podrían votar en contra
de donald trump y entonces así llegará
una votación cercana a los 45 votos en
contra
pues en contra del impeachment y 455
votos a favor de el impeachment a favor
de que se le acuse al presidente trump
de insurrección sin embargo se necesitan
esos dos tercios se necesitan que sean
17 senadores republicanos los que
terminen votando en contra de donald
trump a favor del impeachment para qué
el ex-presidente donald trump se ha
hallado culpable lo que muchos analistas
dicen es que esto no va a ocurrir porque
muchos senadores republicanos que aunque
fue pueden estar personalmente en contra
de lo que hizo donald trump el 6 de
enero no van a votar en contra de él en
el impeachment porque no tienen el
capital político ellos asumirían un
riesgo muy alto políticamente y entonces
esto haría que no puedan reelegirse en
un futuro en sus seis tomas legislativas
si precisamente ya la agencia ap ha
comenzado a enviar algunas alertas en
las que dice que ya son suficientes los
votos de los senadores que absuelven a
donald trump debido a la cantidad de
votos pues ya sería prácticamente muy
difícil para que la votación a favor de
una condena contra donald trump pues sea
concretada por lo que entonces pues
prácticamente ya el presidente sería
absuelto que era uno de los escenarios
posibles de estas dos caras de la moneda
escuchemos cristóbal y televidentes lo
que está
yendo allí en el senado en eeuu
es el absuelto de los cargos en su
contra
señor presidente se reconoce el día de
la mayoría señor presidente envíe una
orden se reportará por parte del
asistente orden deje el secretario se ha
dirigido a comunicar al secretario de
estado como fue proveído por la regla 23
de las reglas de procedimientos y
prácticas en el senado y cuando hay un
juicio de impeachment y también a la
cámara de representantes el juicio del
senado en el caso de lyon trump
transmitir una copia certificada del
juicio a cada uno sin objeción la orden
será ingresada
presidente
[Música]
pasó al senado que es juez bajo el cargo
sin ninguna objeción esta moción es
acordada
en sanidad
el país importador
las fuerzas de seguridad costarán a los
fiscales de la cámara fuera de la cámara
del senado
bueno pues ahí lo tienen ustedes no hay
suficientes votos en el senado en la
cámara alta del congreso de eeuu para
condenar al expresidente donald trump
quien era acusado por haber apoyado esa
insurrección del pasado 6 de enero que
terminó con la toma del capitolio en la
ciudad de washington por parte de
seguidores del presidente de donald
trump a pesar de las denuncias que
hicieron los demócratas y todo este
movimiento que hicieron en el congreso
de eeuu pues eso también entonces la
defensa que presentó allí el
expresidente donald trump y la votación
pues termina hoy a por lo menos llega a
un punto en que sería irreversible la
votación conforme ha tenido su
desarrollo para que tenga un resultado
en contra del ex presidente por lo tanto
pues ya ya se puede confirmar que no hay
suficientes votos para que donald trump
a sea condenado por estas acusaciones
entonces finalizar y así este segundo
juicio político en contra de donald
trump recordemos que la mitad de su
mandato también fue acusado como les
decía por haber pedido que investigarán
al hijo del actual presidente joe biden
y la relación que podría tener con
empresas ucranianas más adelante vamos a
tener invitados aquí en france24 para
analizar me confirman entonces que ya
los tenemos vamos entonces a analizar
qué significa qué significa esta
votación a nivel político para eeuu
comienzo preguntándole a ángel leal en
la ciudad de miami ángel gracias por
estar con nosotros aquí en france24 este
era un escenario posible era un
escenario que estaba previsto porque
pues obviamente esto tenía dos caras de
la moneda
qué carga política o qué costo político
tiene entonces para los demócratas toda
esta semana de juicio político toda esta
campaña en contra del expresidente
donald trump como queda entonces el
partido demócrata
creo que realmente le fue muy bien hay
que entender que las probabilidades de
que sea con víctor press el expresidente
de trump eran casi nulas ya que requería
67 votos constitucionalmente 2 tercera
parte del senado un voto de 57 a 43
hasta aborde que sea convicto realmente
representa un voto bipartidista y
segunda vez es la primera vez en la
historia que un presidente se le inició
un juicio político por en dos ocasiones
primera vez la historia que eso ocurre
lograron presentar su caso con evidencia
conmovedora y lograron poner en duda el
resultado hoy con el tema de los
testigos al final acordaron a la
estipulación de la declaración de la
representante del estado de washington
que creo que fue una evidencia
importante para ellos y todo esto lo
hicieron en cinco días para no
interrumpir la agenda legislativa del
presidente de baires
y pienso que a pesar de que estoy seguro
que estaba buscando que el ex mandatario
sea convicto y descalificado y que ellos
en sus corazones y en sus realidades
consideraron que el exmandatario incitó
la insurrección y puso en peligro
nuestra democracia al final creo que
pueden quedar satisfecho con el
resultado que obtuvieron el día de hoy
el señor robert de valència también se
une a esta conversación desde la ciudad
de nueva york y le pregunto entonces
robert qué significa este resultado
entonces para donald trump una de las
cartas que tenía el partido demócrata
era ese segmento 3 de la enmienda 14 de
la constitución de eeuu que prohíbe que
personas que apoyan insurrecciones
contra eeuu puedan aspirar a tener
cargos públicos entonces aquí queda
carta blanca entonces para que donald
trump pueda aspirar a un cargo público
posiblemente la presidencia nuevamente
bueno primero que todo buenas tardes y
muchísimas gracias por la invitación yo
creo que el presidente dentro no está
fuera de peligro totalmente si
obviamente lo acabamos de ver es un voto
partida como dice el ilimitado y se
trató de él
y esos mecanismos posibles para
argumentar de que no solamente fue lo
que ocurrió el 6 de enero sino también
un compendio de una retórica que ya
venía dándose lugar desde hace muchos
meses
bueno políticamente queda habilitado
para que pueda lanzarse a la presidencia
del próximo el próximo 2024 sin embargo
hay que hay que tener en cuenta lo
siguiente
en estos momentos haciendo un proceso
criminal penal en el estado de georgia
precisamente por tratar de revertir los
resultados en ese estado cuando lo
escuchamos de parte de un reportaje del
washington pausa en el cual se muestra
al a
interior presidente de persuadir al
secretario de estado de georgia en
aumentar los votos en contra los votos
del correcto a como diera luz
jugar
precisamente roberto vamos vamos a
interrumpir aquí su intervención porque
estamos teniendo problemas con el audio
y con la conexión vamos a intentar
mejorarlo para que usted pueda
explicarnos bien y hacer análisis con
nosotros mientras tanto va a conversar
con cristóbal vázquez nuestro
corresponsal en washington cristóbal ya
está el voto definitivo 57 contra 43
estamos hablando que siete republicanos
entonces votaron a favor de una condena
contra el expresidente trump a quienes
fueron entonces estos senadores
fueron richard moore fue también para mí
fue en esas que durante los ataques del
6 de enero se dice que estaba en la casa
blanca con el expresidente donald trump
fue mitt romney de yuta que se esperaba
que votará en contra mitt romney fue ex
candidato a la presidencia y fue un
abierto opositor en el partido
republicano del ex presidente donald
trump durante esos últimos cuatro años
de administración también está lisa
murkowski senadora de atlanta también
opositora a don otro a pesar de ser
republicana y casi y de luisiana él fue
él era un voto bisagra que los
republicanos estaban tratando de
convencer de que votará en contra de el
impeachment pero lo hizo a favor sin
embargo usted lo mencionaba bien fueron
57 votos a favor del impeachment 43 en
contra es decir no se logran los 67 que
se esperaban por una diferencia de 10
votos y donald trump
así es cristóbal esos son los votos ya
definitivos los repito son 57 votos a
favor de la absolución del ex presidente
343 a favor de una condena es el
resultado ya definitivo allí de los
senadores ángel en la ciudad de miami a
lo largo de esta mañana vimos un momento
como que parecía una vuelta de tuerca
por parte de los demócratas cuando
pidieron al senado que votaran a favor
de aprobar la presencia de testigos
sobre el llamar algunos testigos para
ampliar un poco la base de argumentos
para condenar al expresidente donald
trump a esto fue un acto un poco
desesperado de los demócratas porque
finalmente no concretó nada ni sumó ni
resto
no yo pienso que puede
el acto estratégico basado en una
noticia de última hora que filtró la
noche anterior que fue la declaración
precisamente y discúlpeme que haga
referencia al dispositivo de la
representante james herrera volver del
estado de washington
en la declaración básicamente y ella
relata una conversación de el líder
minoritario de la cámara de
representantes quieren ver partes del
partido republicano con el presidente de
trump donde básicamente hay esta llamada
el 6 de enero y le pide públicamente y
forzosamente de que pare la insurrección
la protesta y el presidente inició
inicialmente repitió la mentira de que
era antifaz y que que había sido ante
ésta quien había incursionado el
capítulo y buck coats y rehusó eso y le
dice presidente de que esto eran
personas que apoyaban y grupos que
apoyaban a trump es entonces cuando de
acuerdo a mccarthy el presidente le dice
bueno que ven pienso que entonces esa
persona está más interesada en la
elección que usted
desde entonces la representante herrera
volver dice como yo públicamente anuncie
mi decisión para votar a favor del
artículo de acusación he compartido
estos detalles de esa conversación con
mis constituyentes y mis colegas
múltiples veces o sea de que realmente
hicieron introducir esa evidencia
buscando la forma de que estipularán de
que esa conversación tuvo lugar y es
importante porque esa conversación
demuestra un estado de mente de que este
intento de insurrección era el posible
objetivo de las acciones del
exmandatario ángel y también antes de
comenzar este juicio incluso durante las
elecciones y a lo largo del mes de
diciembre de a principios de enero hasta
esta insurrección del 6 de enero se
hablaba y se especulaba mucho de
fracturas al interior del partido
republicano en torno a la figura de
donald trump hay personas y seguidores
de este partido
les gusta la tendencia política de este
partido pero no la forma como gobernó el
expresidente de trump o la tendencia que
él marcó a lo largo de estos cuatro años
y decían que esa ruptura iba a estar muy
evidente en este tipo de escenarios en
este juicio político pero claramente la
votación del día de hoy con 57 votos a
favor de absorber al presidente pues
demuestra que entonces los republicanos
no están tan fracturados como creíamos
discrepo respetuosamente y yo sí creo
que están sumamente fracturados
claramente hay dos grupos el dentro del
partido republicano
el grupo conservador de los cuales siete
de ellos votaron a favor de que sea
convicto del expresidente trump y el
grupo autócrata que está siguiendo la
línea del exmandatario trump y yo no
puedo decir que parece ser de que el el
segmento del partido leal a trump existe
tiene cierto poder pero producto de este
juicio político bipartidista tanto en la
cámara donde diez republicanos votaron a
favor del artículo d
de de acusación y donde hoy vimos siete
republicanos votar a favor de que sea
convicto yo creo que han perdido mucho
peso político pero indiscutiblemente el
partido republicano está fracturado
a tal punto de que inclusive muchos
miembros del partido republicano están
considerando
separarse y crear su propio partido que
sea más fiel a los principios históricos
del partido republicano
angelia continuó hablando con usted
quiero que hagamos balance entonces de
la posición en la que queda el partido
republicano ya hablamos del demócrata
vale la pena hacer también el balance de
los republicanos después de este juicio
político retomó la conexión con
cristóbal vázquez en la ciudad de
washington cristóbal entonces que sigue
ahora para donald trump para los
republicanos y para el senado después de
este de esta semana de juicio político
y es que precisamente lo que había
también era un miedo un miedo a que si
donald trump no contaba con el apoyo del
partido republicano en este segundo
juicio político pues su reacción
iba a ser crear un nuevo partido se
habla del partido llamado el partido
patriota el paper sporting que iba a
crear donald trump que ha insinuado en
varias ocasiones que puede crear y
crearía para poder alinearse mucho más
con la derecha de eeuu y pues darle más
lugar a estas ideas más de derechas más
conservadoras y no estar aferrado al
partido republicano que tiene algunos
representantes de centro que no lo han
apoyado que lo han criticado que lo han
cuestionado que han puesto en duda sus
políticas y sus intereses durante los
últimos cuatro años cuando estuvo en la
casa blanca y ahí el interés del ex
presidente de nosotros de crear su
propio partido entonces el miedo y
muchos analistas están diciendo que el
miedo que tuvieron varios senadores al
no apoyar
en este segundo juicio político era
precisamente ese que si votaban en
contra de donald trump pues de alguna
manera
de alguna manera habrían esa puerta para
que el ex presidente creara su propio
partido dividiera entonces aún más el
partido republicano y en eventuales
elecciones tanto regionales como
nacionales pues el voto entonces se
dividiera el voto del centro y
centroderecha se dividiera entre el
nuevo partido de donald trump y el
partido republicano hay que mencionar
que donald trump tuvo 75 millones de
votos en la elección presidencial es un
capital político inmenso es la mitad de
la población apta para votar en este
país así que muchos republicanos a pesar
incluso de no estar de acuerdo con el
presidente de donald trump querían de
alguna manera pues mantener el partido
unido mostrar su apoyo y así evitar
cualquier tipo de fragmentación futura
hace pocos minutos el ex presidente de
donald trump ha recibido de muy buena
manera este resultado de la votación
haber quedado absuelto de este juicio
político cristóbal y también ha dicho
que todo este
político de este juicio es simplemente
parte de una casa de brujas que adelanta
el partido demócrata de otros sectores
políticos allí en eeuu ya retomamos la
conexión con robert de valència en las
ciudades de nueva york en robert retomó
entonces algo de lo que está diciendo
nuestro corresponsal en washington esa
posibilidad de que el presidente perdón
expresidente donald trump
arme filas y conforme un partido
político aparte está el escenario
político de eeuu presto a una acción
parecida algo así
pues vamos a ver si esa idea todavía
sigue en pie después de lo que ocurrió
al día de hoy porque lo que ha
demostrado es que hay una parte del
partido republicano que todavía se
siente amenazado por la presencia de
donald trump y no hay que negar quiere
una trampa a pesar de que no es
presidente y de que no tiene un púlpito
en la figura de twitter sigue siendo una
figura política importante y que tiene
grande y una gran influencia sobre
algunos legisladores de hecho lo vimos
el día de hoy aunque sí fue un aumento
un poco más el número de senadores
republicanos que se unieron a los
demócratas antes se hablaba de cinco y
hoy vemos que fueron siete en la revista
político hablaba incluso de unos diez
republicanos que podían votar
culpable o señalar culpabilidad
presidente ex presidente de donald trump
pero yo creo que en vista de lo ocurrido
el día de hoy pues de cierta manera le
da fuerza a donald trump yo creo que no
podemos olvidar lo siguiente si bien el
presidente perdió por 7 millones de
votos en el voto popular
el margen de victoria de bailén y trump
viendo al colegio electoral pues
realmente fue mínimo sigue siendo una
figura importante de hecho vemos que
cada vez que los republicanos se alzaban
alza su voz en contra de donald trump
otros legisladores republicanos pues
amenazaban con que sus carreras iban a
digamos a marchitarse a no años a no ser
digamos a no continuar su progreso y
esto lo vemos por ejemplo cuando
marjorie taylor greene amenazó incluso a
la representante del estado de
washington que había corroborado esa
conversación entre está entre el doctor
y kevin mccarthy que es el líder de la
minoría republicana en la cámara baja
así que no sé si todavía el surja esa
idea de construir un nuevo partido
porque obviamente lo que hemos visto el
día de hoy es que con la venia de los
republicanos
donald trump sigue siendo una figura
preponderante dentro de ese partido y en
vista de que ya fue absuelto pues se
puede encaminar al 2024 y como estaba
señalando anteriormente
antes de que se cortara la señal era que
todavía tiene un juicio criminal tiene
un juicio penal no sabemos cuál va a ser
el futuro del presidente de nosotros y
pueden llegar a ser encarcelados y
puedan ser a nivel y está de alguna
manera pero políticamente la sacó barata
como seguiría coloquialmente
y es que estos resultados tan reñidos en
unas elecciones de gran escala como las
elecciones presidenciales en eeuu con
esos márgenes tan estrechos en los
resultados lo que demuestra es que
claramente hay dos perspectivas
distintas de lo que quieren los
ciudadanos de eeuu y el apoyo por los
dos candidatos en ese momento pues es
considerable fueron votaciones inmensas
tomando en cuenta la situación de la
pandemia la situación económica y el
escenario en el que se encuentra eeuu
robert como queda entonces el presidente
joe biden en este momento después de
este juicio político que se puede
esperar entonces por el lado de la casa
blanca
el presidente de byn de había se había
aislado de ese proceso no quiere decir
que no estaba apoyando el juicio
político sino que él entendiendo que hay
una situación que es aún más
comprometedora y es el apoyo en el
paquete de ayuda que quiere lanzar a
través del senado quien en estos
momentos en su mayoría demócrata se
tiene en cuenta el voto de desempate de
que a managers son más de un billón de
dólares los que se quieren aprobar y yo
creo que eso de cierta manera fue lo que
impulsó a los demócratas a evitar llamar
a jueces perdonando a jueces lo perdona
a testigos y que se prolongará este este
proceso este juicio político que de
cierta manera yo creo que ambos partidos
querían que terminar lo más pronto
posible se hablaba incluso de que el
lunes ya se hubiese tenido resultados
finales y bueno lo sorprendente fue que
hoy se dio ya este veredicto
y yo creo que parte de eso es
precisamente porque todavía hay muchos a
muchas asignaturas pendientes
del paquete de ayuda de lo que llamamos
el paquete de alivio por el cob y
todavía necesita ser aprobado por el
senado también algunas nominaciones al
gabinete ya otros cargos políticos en la
rama ejecutiva lo cual también requiere
de la atención del senado y entendiendo
que un impeachment requiere de toda la
atención del senado pues esos programas
quedan relegados a esas funciones juezas
y esos deberes quedan rezagados así que
obviamente los estadounidenses yo creo
que no le prestaron mucha atención al
imperio en a brawn por un porcentaje
considerable pero muchas personas
realmente están esperando a que las
vacunas lleguen que lleguen en el
estímulo económico ese cheque de 1.400
dólares que tanto están esperando porque
indudablemente pues hay una situación
aún más grave todavía y es que este país
todavía está a penas no se ha levantado
totalmente de la crisis del córdoba
virus así que eso lo que están también
mirando los estadounidenses de que los
demócratas no simplemente es digamos no
tengan esa percepción de que quieren
buscar una venganza una retaliación por
en contra de una acción cuando fueron
puestos en el poder precisamente para
paliar esta crisis que vive está
escribió el país porque las prioridades
de los estadounidenses en este momento
está como usted lo dice hacerle frente a
la pandemia del cobre 19 y reactivar la
economía que ha afectado a millones de
estadounidenses en retomó la conexión
con ángel leal en la ciudad de miami
ángel este tipo de procedimientos de
juicios políticos a lo largo de la
historia de eeuu
sientan precedentes que lección deja
entonces este procedimiento que
elecciones podemos aprender y
conclusiones de este procedimiento
bueno que con constitucionalmente
procede un juicio político contra un
funcionario de la rama ejecutiva que
deja de ocupar el cargo bien sea porque
haya sido expulsado porque haya
renunciado en este caso por haber
terminado el mandato pero creo que a
pesar de que constitucionalmente procede
la elección quedó clara de que se debe
de iniciar el proceso de juicio político
y debe de culminar mientras que la
persona ocupe el cargo político es decir
que debe de ser un proceso de remoción y
descalificación creo que gran parte del
motivo y políticamente muchos
republicanos están escudando con el
argumento constitucional de que esto no
procedía porque ya era una persona que
dejó de ocupar el poder y era un
ciudadano privado entonces yo creo que
para el futuro las lecciones que si se
va a iniciar un juicio político que se
aseguren de que se pueda culminar
durante el plazo de la persona en
cuestión
si usted está conectándose a la señal de
france 24 estamos haciendo aquí análisis
de los resultados de la votación que
todo lugar es algunos minutos en la
ciudad de washington hay el senado voto
ya para poner fin a este juicio político
contra el ex presidente de donald trump
el resultado son 57 votos a favor de la
condena del ex mandatario y 43 en contra
de unas cifras pues que fueron
insuficientes por el lado de esta
iniciativa demócrata para llegar
entonces a una condena contra el ex
presidente me piden insistentemente que
haga la aclaración retomo la conexión
con cristóbal vázquez quien es el
corresponsal de france 24 ha estado
siguiendo allí a lo largo de la jornada
de este proceso en el senado
cristóbal que han dicho entonces la
bancada de los republicanos allí en el
senado
claro reacciones ya empezamos a escuchar
de los senadores que salen de la
plenaria del senado y hablan con los
periodistas entre ellos mitch mcconnell
que fue uno de los críticos más grandes
de el expresidente donald trump por su
reacción el 6 de enero entre otras cosas
por no haber enviado ayuda por no haber
condenado por no haber hecho nada
después de que sus simpatizantes
violentos se tomaran el capitolio mitch
mcconnell dice que los simpatizantes
violentos de donald trump fueron
alimentados con falsedades durante mucho
tiempo por el hombre más poderoso en
redes sociales en referencia al ex
presidente do noso lo que es curioso sin
embargo es que en mitch mcconnell que es
el líder de los republicanos en el
senado es uno de los senadores que más
tiempo lleva en el en la cámara alta
pues votó en contra del impeachment es
decir apoyó a el ex presidente
donald trump a pesar de que sale de la
cámara sale de la plenaria y
manifiesta que efectivamente fue la
incitación del expresidente donald trump
que derivó en los actos de violencia vio
que así también de luisiana dijo que
pues que él además votó en contra de
onoto rompe es decir apoyó el
impeachment y dice que pues ya hay que
de alguna manera voltear la página que
el país y la constitución son más
importantes y que ahora pues hay que
enfocarse en lo que viene cristo al
ángel roberto quiero que hagamos una
retrospectiva de los hechos que llevaron
a que el ex presidente de donald trump
llegara hasta este escenario un segundo
juicio político en donde nuevamente
demócratas y republicanos midieron
fuerzas en torno a las opiniones que
tuvieron a lo largo de estos cuatro años
durante el gobierno de donald trump y
pues así fue como llegó hasta el
escenario del día de hoy el resultado de
esta votación
estas son las palabras por las que
donald trump es acusado de incitar a la
inscripción
durante un mitin de cara a la segunda
vuelta de las elecciones al senado por
georgia el presidente saliente pidió a
los ciudadanos defender la victoria que
según él le fue robada pese a que la
justicia lo desestimó
los demócratas radicales están tratando
de tomarse las sillas del senado por
georgia para que puedan ejercer poder
absoluto desenfrenado y sin límites
sobre cada aspecto de sus vidas
[Aplausos]
estos demócratas liberales no tomarán
esta casa blanca
vamos a luchar como demonios se los digo
ahora mismo
en el mismo acto trump presionó el
vicepresidente mike pence a no
certificar el 6 de enero la victoria de
joe biden en las elecciones del 3 de
noviembre precisamente el día de la
certificación from convocó a sus
seguidores a una manifestación frente al
capitolio aquí les pidió marchar hasta
la sede del congreso para defender su
voto hemos venido a exigir que el
congreso haga lo correcto
y cuente solo los electores que fueron
asignados de acuerdo a la ley
[Aplausos]
sé que todos aquí van a marchar pronto
hacia el capitolio para pacífica y
patrióticamente hacer que sus voces sean
escuchadas
y siguieron sus órdenes después del
asalto al capitolio
trump divulgó un vídeo en el que
agradecía a sus seguidores y les pedía
irse a casa con uno sin condenar los
actos vandálicos
no fue hasta el día siguiente que
rechazó la violencia y por primera vez
dijo que entregaría el poder a joe biden
el 20 de enero desde entonces ha
entregado discursos más moderados en los
que dice que los asaltantes al capitolio
no tienen nada que ver con lo que él
representa
esa violencia va en contra de todo lo
que creó y todo lo que nuestro
movimiento representa ningún seguidor
verdadero mío apoyaría la violencia
política
me respetaría a las fuerzas de la ley
ningún verdadero seguidor mío amenazaría
a otro estadounidense
si usted hizo elogio de eso no está
apoyando nuestro movimiento y está
atacando a nuestro país ahora casi sin
embargo aún está por verse si con una
semana de distanciamiento puede borrar
más de dos meses de llamados a la
división y denuncias de fraude sin
fundamento
roberto en valencia en la ciudad de
nueva york veíamos las imágenes de esa
insurrección del 6 de enero las imágenes
que le dieron la vuelta al mundo los
demócratas las calificaron como unos
hechos de violencia que pusieron en
riesgo la democracia eeuu y también las
instituciones de este país en que queda
entonces este tema de la insurrección
del 6 de enero
cuando quieres lo que queda a mí mi
versión o por lo menos mi observación es
la siguiente el partido republicano
siempre fue un partido que fue muy
permisivo con el presidente don 8 es una
persona que nunca ha cambiado de parecer
hacia una figura controversial durante
toda su vida y esto no solamente es un
producto del azar solamente lo que
ocurrió en ser y tener incluso esta
retórica es racista por decirlo
claramente yo creo que esto viene
incluso desde hace años es decir desde
el momento en que el cemento su carrera
política llamando a que el presidente ex
presidente barack obama ni siquiera era
un estadounidense nacido en tierra
estadounidense sino que era un que había
nacido en kenia y había iniciado este
movimiento nativista de hace más de 10
años y luego volvió a redoblar sus
esfuerzos con una retórica
antiinmigrante llamando a los hispanos
ya los mexicanos específicamente
tachándolos de narcotraficantes y de
drogadictos y personas que cometen
violaciones y que algunos hispanos eran
buenos
luego redoblar la apuesta en el 2017
cuando
con esas manifestaciones en
charlottesville virginia diciendo que
tanto los manifestantes digamos en
contra de los movimientos de la
supremacía blanca diciendo que ambos
lados hay buenas personas que fue
precisamente un evento que llevó a
jobvite de lanzarse a la presidencia en
aquel año y vemos toda esta está este
compendio de digamos de una retórica
bastante incendiaria no solamente envió
y el directo sino también por medio de
twitter que es la observación que vemos
el día de hoy de que aquí se siente un
precedente bastante peligroso aquí se
puede decir un presidente puede causar
este tipo de desmanes a dos semanas de
entregar su presidencia y aún así el
congreso pues no opta por por castigarlo
bueno hay que decir que la cámara baja
silos y lo señaló culpable y eso yo creo
que es el punto que se pierde a veces en
esa conversación de que este proceso era
inconstitucional pues no es
inconstitucional porque la cámara baja
me encontró culpable antes de entregar
el poder y fue en michoacán alquien
extendió la fecha para hacer el juicio
del senado después del 20 de enero y
ahora son los republicanos que dicen que
es inconstitucional porque el presidente
no está en ejercicio entonces de ahí es
donde queda esa observación me parece
que deja un muy mal precedente porque
eso quiere decir que cualquier
presidente de cualquier partido y que
largan las mismas aspiraciones de la
trón puede volver a hacer esto sin
ningún tipo de consecuencia política y
sin ningún tipo de consecuencia penal es
a la observación
sigue habiendo reacciones por parte del
ex presidente de donald trump acaba de
decir que le da la bienvenida a esta
absolución
en este juicio político también ha dicho
que su movimiento hacer a eeuu grande de
nuevo solamente está comenzando o acaba
de empezar es algunas de las reacciones
ángel en la ciudad de miami la misma
pregunta entonces en que queda este
movimiento de esta insurrección y este
movimiento de seguidores de trompas del
6 de enero
como pasará entonces esto la historia
que lecciones le deja a los
estadounidenses ya la política de eeuu
bueno es una mancha sobre la democracia
de los estados unidos de américa y no
doy por terminado el hecho de las
posibles consecuencias hay una
investigación activa en el condado
fulton estado de georgia por
interferencia electoral en contra del
exmandatario también sabemos de
investigaciones que no tienen que ver
con los eventos del 6 de enero en el
distrito de manhattan en nueva york por
parte del fiscal cyrus vance y
recordemos que todavía está por
confirmarse la nominación de maryland
como fiscal general de los estados
unidos- ex juez de la corte del circuito
federal del distrito de colombia es una
de las cortes más poderosas antes de la
corte suprema de ser confirmado
garland yo pienso que pudiera existir
todavía la posibilidad de una
investigación a nivel penal de haber
participado o incitado la insurrección
a pesar de el hecho de que no alcanzaron
los 67 votos en un juicio político que
en gran parte se determinó este es el
resultado por motivos políticos yo creo
que todavía este tema no ha terminado
claro este es un juicio político pero
hay otros escenarios en el legislativo a
través de las leyes de eeuu cobijando a
todos los ciudadanos entre ellos a
donald trump como simplemente un
ciudadano de eeuu puede llegar a otro
escenario en donde pueda ser juzgado
nuevamente y llevado a la corte reiteró
este marcador final para que la gente
esté en contexto y sepa cuál fue el
resultado de este juicio político fueron
57 votos a favor
d
pero quedó solamente 43 votos a favor de
la condena del presidente donde el
expresidente donald trump y 57 entonces
pues que lo absuelven retomó la conexión
con cristóbal vázquez que está allí en
el senado para hablar algunas de las
reacciones que han tenido los demócratas
que fue la bancada que comenzó inició
esta iniciativa en el legislativo hace
algunas semanas y que concluyó el día de
hoy
exactamente fueron los representantes a
la cámara los que acusan al expresidente
de tron de insurrección
action era el líder de los demócratas
del partido del partido demócrata en el
senado uno de los primeros en reaccionar
tras conocerse la decisión pide su
axioma en plenaria que por favor se le
den diez minutos a los senadores que
quieran reaccionar él es el primero en
tomar la palabra y dice que la decisión
que toma la plenaria del senado es lo
más antiamericano posible dice jackson
que esto es un insulto para los policías
del capitolio para la gente que luchó en
contra de estos extremistas de estos
simpatizantes de donald trump que
violentamente se tomaron el capitolio y
que el asunto quede sin resolverse que
no haya un responsable es simplemente un
insulto a estas personas que pusieron en
riesgo sus vidas para defender el
capitolio dice que esto de además dejará
una mancha en el partido republicano que
afectará
la democracia y dice que es simplemente
muy anti ético y antidemocrático lo que
ocurrió hoy acá en el capitolio
es que sorprendió al mundo entero
cristóbal lo que sucedió ese 6 de enero
el mundo entero se sorprendió con esas
escenas de esa toma en el capitolio en
la ciudad de washington veíamos a estos
seguidores de trump entrar a la sala de
la cámara alta también por los pasillos
y a las oficinas de los diferentes
representantes y senadores buscando
información dañando parte de esta
edificación de este edificio público
fueron imágenes que le dio le dieron la
vuelta al mundo porque antes no se había
visto una insurrección parecida en la
historia reciente de eeuu y pues el
precedente queda como dice usted para
una mancha para algunos para algunas
formaciones políticas y también algunas
elecciones como lo estábamos hablando
con nuestros analistas para la historia
de eeuu robert valencia entonces que
sigue en el siguiente capítulo de la
historia política de donald trump desde
su perspectiva ahora que ha quedado
fuera libre de estas culpas pese a que
algunos republicanos insisten en que el
presidente si tuvo algo que ver en esta
insurrección aquí lo vemos en
de las alertas dicen que él es
responsable por los hechos del 6 de
enero
y vale la pena rescatar lo que dijo el
invitado que es muy cierto y es este es
un proceso político no es un proceso
penal de hecho y voy a señalar eso que
acaban de escribir de parte de la cadena
cnn
haciendo una observación que acaba de
que precisamente acaba de hacer
mitch mcconnell diciendo que ahora es la
justicia penal la que es el escenario
para juzgar a donald trump y cito dice
el presidente de anchor todavía sigue
siendo de cierta manera responsable por
todo lo que él hizo durante su mandato y
que él no se ha salido con la suya
todavía me parece que es una una postura
bastante interesante por parte de mis
marcano al tratar de llevar este juicio
político a llevarlo a un a un juicio
criminal ahora yo creo que aquí hay una
cosa muy importante que señala porque en
la corte penal aquí lo que esto lo
pueden señalar algunos letrados legales
o letrados en en temas de derecho y es
que si se llega
llevamos este caso a una corte penal
aquí se puede aplicar precedentes de
cuide del juicio que se ha declarado que
se definieron en la corte suprema ya hay
un caso y un precedente hace algunas
décadas cuando un líder del ku kux klan
había hecho un llamado a una
insurrección sino similar a lo que
ocurrió obviamente el 6 de enero pero
donde su el lenguaje a pesar de ser
incendiario estaba protegido por la
primera enmienda y yo creo que en esa
barra tan alta que ha dejado ese caso
aquí es donde las palabras del
presidente de nosotros podrían estar
protegidas bajo la primera enmienda y de
hecho ser exonerado nuevamente aún así
creo que como presidente faltó a su
obligación de defender la constitución
porque volvemos al tema del condado de
fulton en georgia en donde él trató de
revertir los resultados del 6 de enero
perdón del secreto del 3 de noviembre
pero llamó al señor rapids prayer que es
el secretario
de estado de georgia y que trató de
convencerlo para que cambiara los
resultados y se está haciendo ese vídeo
proceso otro que es otra cosa que yo
quisiera señalar aquí que me parece que
es importante es la figura del
impeachment a nivel legislativo muchos
han hecho a la crítica diciendo que como
era posible hacer un juicio político si
las personas que son jurados y pues
tienen intereses políticos en este caso
los republicanos porque los letrados
legales incluso los conservadores decían
que los republicanos tenían la
obligación de ver los méritos las
evidencias que realmente culpan a lo
natural de todo lo que ocurrió pero aquí
hay otro motivo distinto y es la
protección de sus intereses y de sus
réditos políticos entonces cuando hay un
conflicto de interés de semejante
magnitud realmente el senado debe ser el
jurado y pues en un caso como éste
entonces aquí lo algunas de los algunos
de los planteamientos que hemos visto es
que es la corte suprema quien debe de
definir
si el presidente en una circunstancia
similar es culpable o es absuelto de
este caso porque dentro del senado hay
muchos intereses de por medio y esto fue
claramente ideado el día de hoy los
republicanos votaron a favor de una
persona que claramente cocino esta
figura esta gran mentira como la han
llamado incluso los managers de la casa
de la cámara de representantes que llevó
que estaban querían enunciará a donald
trump y eso fue lo que llevó a las
consecuencias a lo que vimos el 6 de
enero así que también se plantea ese
escenario si cierra figura del
impeachment e incluso la enmienda 25 son
recursos robert ticos efectivos para
realmente llevar un juicio político
justo valga la redundancia
debo cortarlo porque quiero quiero
concluir con ángel preguntándole quién
puede llevar entonces ante una corte
penal éstas acciones perpetradas por el
ex presidente
donald trump
el departamento de justicia de hecho
estaba mirando el estatuto discúlpame
que haga referencia a dispositivos
capítulo 18 sección 23 83 el código
federal estadounidense quien incita
ponga en pie asista o de alguna forma
colabora en cualquier rebelión o
instrucción contra la autoridad de los
eeuu será culpable de de este delito
puede ser en cáncer o hasta por 10 años
multa 2 es el código federal también en
el estado de georgia hay un código
estatal que dice quien a sabiendas de
vivir deliberadamente priva de fraude o
intenta privar o defraudar a los
residentes de un estado de un proceso
electoral conducido de manera justa e
imparcial entonces este es el tipo de
acusación que pudiéramos ver a nivel
penal en el estado de georgia en una
causa estatal lo cual lo llevaría la
fiscal estatal del condado fulton a
nivel federal sería el departamento de
justicia el vidriado liderado
brevemente por mi recording después de
que se ha confirmado y el asignará un
abogado a cargo de este caso ángeles
robert y cristóbal muchas gracias por
habernos acompañado en esta transmisión
especial de france 24 con los resultados
de este juicio político de la votación
de este juicio político que deja ya
absuelto al ex presidente don al trono
ustedes gracias por la sintonía y sigan
con la programación de francia 24 buenas
tardes para todos
[Música]